this morning the fbi is investigating
what may become one of the world's
largest ransomware attacks a
russia-based cyber criminal group called
our evil demanded a 70 million dollar
ransom last night
these are the same hackers who hit a
giant meat packing company over memorial
day
the new attack affects hundreds of
businesses including financial service
firms and a european grocery chain
senior investigative correspondent
katherine herrich reports
hackers hit i.t software company cassaya
friday
they infected some of its customers that
rely on the network management system
including swedish grocery chain co-op
which closed
most of its 800 stores for a second day
sunday
because their cash register software
shut down
lots of criminal organizations are
finding out that they can get paid
millions of dollars to disrupt our
economy
if you compromise cassaya you can then
take over
the cassaya infrastructure to help
broadcast ransomware
to all of those unwitting victims after
recent ransomware breaches at colonial
pipeline
and jbs a major meat processor homeland
security warned in this recent
intelligence report
obtained by cbs news that ransomware
attacks are likely to increase in the
near and long term
these are largely russian-affiliated
entities these organizations are able to
operate with relative impunity
because there's not really any
enforcement from
the russian state in michigan saturday
president biden said
intelligence officials are investigating
the director of the intelligence
community
give me a deep dive on what's happened
last month he warned the russian
president to reign in cyber criminals
or face a strong u.s response if it is
either with the knowledge of and or a
consequence of
russia then i told putin we will respond
in a statement kaseya said customer
teams continue to work
around the clock to resolve the issue
and restore
our customers to service cyber security
experts tell cbs news that launching the
attack on a holiday weekend allowed
cyber criminals to burrow into networks
and they do expect more victims to come
forward
once businesses fully reopen on tuesday
gail
all right catherine thank you very much